so as I crashed into the cold dark water  of the Pacific I realized a few things  hey I have no idea where I'm going B  salt water stings C I shouldn't even be  on this planet right now but I am why  because you shot me I know you shot me  alright I heard you the first time you  don't have to pile it on good grief  I'm wet I'm cold there's a fish on my  head and clearly I'm not gonna be able  to do this on my own  alright get in the truck really you're  gonna help me I guess it is a little bit  my fault that all this is happening to  you not a little bit entirely it is  entirely your fault it's entirely my  fault  are you coming yes road trip  what am i doing  here to protect my friends we gotta lay  low  [Music]  you